[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right iron lord podcast lords of
gaming.net lore cognato here with the
amazing nicholas downey editor of
lordsgaming.net how we doing sir
doing great doing great having a great
time you know excited to talk about what
we're talking about yeah it seems like
we got something really cool to talk
about so right out the gate let's uh
give our thanks to microsoft and xbox
for providing us a preview coverage of
the halo infinite campaign
and uh let's get right into it man this
is highly anticipated you know as far as
you know everybody wanting to know what
this campaign was about to feel and
stuff like that i'll kind of jump off
and then i'll kind of feed off you you
know initially for me
this was one of those situations where
i'm like okay we know about the
skepticism coming in we know that the
the multi-player would pretty much
fairly with strong we know that
multiplayer bait is out right now it's
hitting strong and we're very confident
about that but it all came down to this
campaign can 343 pull this off and my
initial feelings the short brief
feelings was
pleasantly surprised pleasantly
surprised the vibe the feel
you know classic halo but um i didn't
expect to feel this well and especially
with the the before we get into zeta
halo the interior sections of what i
played and um
it really felt uh a lot of verticality
things that i didn't expect in a
campaign game from halo obviously the
weapons feel good shout out to the
mangler the mangler's feeling good out
here man i was really loving the mangler
you know saw some things that you even
mentioned in your amazing article on
lordsagegaming.net um in reference to
the the ammo economy and halo is a game
that i always feel like there's you know
there's a lot of weapons on the ground
you got to use everything to your
disposal while you're fighting the
banish and all this other stuff but what
i really thought was cool was kind of
like the kinetic energy stuff plasma
energy stuff these kind of refill points
that you could use but i wanted to what
was your feel like just initially
campaign more of the uh indoor sections
of the game
yeah so i think the first thing like you
said the verticality is the first thing
that kind of
sent me because it was one of those
things where halo has been always very
much like chief feet on the ground you
know he's moving you're shuffling you're
killing things there is some verticality
to halo like i don't want to take away
there was some decent verticality in
four
um but
this is different this feels
this feels almost like
like i don't wanna set expectations but
in terms of verticality and level design
i want people think more doom 2016
in terms of how you can scale and move
around and how you can
attack enemies and even even in the more
linear
sections
there's options which i always felt was
kind of lacking in halo
yes yes big time big time i think that's
a big key you know just being able to
tackle things from different vantage
points and and so on and so forth and
for me one of the things i noticed
initially was i felt i needed to bump
the difficulty up to a rock just to get
that cool feel but i have to admit like
when i got kind of my first kind of boss
encounter so to speak like it was on and
cracking like i was really it was a
fight
for my life and i was dying so i'm like
okay this is what i want to see and um
i definitely want to talk about just
like we talk about level design we talk
about weapons we're talking about chief
i mean right off the gate we gotta admit
the grappler hook fundamentally changes
how this game is right
it it fundamentally changes how you play
halo like like i've when i saw the
grappling hook when they first kind of
showcased it i was kind of like okay i
can kind of get behind that and like
we've got to play around within the
multiplayer and i was like i really like
this but the fact that it's like this
unlimited charge constant use
ability it keeps you cycling and like it
makes it makes the harder difficulties
more interesting because it's not like
okay as soon as this just as soon as i
pop it this jackal's gonna immediately
snipe me in the head it's like hey i can
zip behind then up and around and i
think it lends itself to making the
which we'll touch on in a bit of course
is the open world aspects more
interesting and just the ability to you
know oh i want that weapon over there
you know you run out of ammo you look
over you grapple the weapon to yourself
or it's just it's such a good mechanic
like automatically if you put a
grappling hook in your game it's
automatically a great game oh automatic
what makes it automatically yeah or
sister buying commando days and and i
want to touch more it's like that part
is really strong but i do i would be
remiss if i didn't talk about what the
elephant in the room is especially for
halo campaign guys because for me
personally you know five didn't resonate
for me you know i'm saying from a
campaign standpoint and one thing
without spoiling i feel like
lore wise
i am really gripped in you know weapon
we're able to have a conversation weapon
we have conversations with the pilot and
i really feel it plays off chief very
well i feel like chief is kind of like
kind of stoic you know kind of per you
know chris and ali but this combination
i thought was strong and another thing i
want to give uh 343 a lot of credit was
you know the audio logs and finding
things i was able to find to come across
a dead person and i'm not going to get
into too deep with that but i was able
to learn so much in these little
narrative beats that i felt already
within the first
couple of missions of playing halo 5 i
felt so obviously infinite that i felt
so more confident than halo 5. i felt
like i'm learning about this universe
and i'm mr casual lord i'm not even like
hardcore lore guy but i'm like okay
y'all hitting the ground running i'm
energized i'm liking what you guys are
talking about and the last point i'll
say is
there's something about the banished i
like
you know they be talking they talk and
they'd be appearing and maybe it's the
brutishness and the the aggressiveness
you know that they didn't have with the
fallen and last thing i said i'll give
you guys i'm talking a lot but the
fallen are still hilarious shout out to
the little guy
the little guys be talking that talk so
i thought it was fun what was i i know
we can't get too deep and low but what
was your feeling of halo infinite lore
wise so far versus what you may have
experienced with five yeah so i like
like yourself i'm even more of a casual
lore guy when it comes to halo like halo
was the co-op with my friends and just
have a blast playing kind of game but
for me it was like you know with you
know it's solo campaign so i'm like
let's see is this something that's going
to engross me and i was really surprised
like you said the audio logs provide all
this in-depth back lore that makes it so
much more
i want to use the word accessible but
it's so much more in your face than you
know you're not treading off the beaten
path to find this information it's being
presented to you in a really easy to
find way like most of the audio logs
it's like oh here's an audio log to the
left of a door so you're going to find
this it's not like you have to go to the
top left corner of a map or anything to
find this it's easily accessible and it
gives you a better idea
of what you're doing and in terms of
enemies
i like the banish so much more because
it they don't have that base level fear
of chief
that so many of the other enemies in
halo do and i think that's what makes it
so great is they're like oh we can crush
him he's one guy who cares about the
smoke yes
yeah and and that's what i'm about it's
like the they're 343's addressing the
fact of how ridiculous it is that chief
can one-man army through anything and
the banister like no that is not gonna
fly here and i like that i love that
yeah because it's something well i hate
bringing up doom because it's so wild to
me because i always said after doom
eternal i'm like there's no way that
halo can do that leap
and i've just i've been really impressed
with what they've been able to do and
how they've managed to
humanize chief and just kind of make the
overall game more entrancing to me
absolutely and it just gives me so much
hope for the future of how this story
will continue because i really felt that
narratively they hit to be strong and
even the relationships between pilot and
and weapon and how they bounce off of
him again humanize them and sometimes
challenge him which is cool and i did
want to move forward as far as we got
that and you know we're going to get
into what the open world has been the
controversy sort of thing but everyone
is kind of worried about you know we've
heard things like hey don't you know far
cry this don't you know do these type of
things where it's so overwhelming so you
know for me that was a question i wanted
to know how 343 was gonna tackle us
because we started off how we started
off but then we get there the first
thing off the bat i will say which was
very
impressive to me initially was
getting out on zeta a halo right and
you're getting out there you see in the
vast world but then because i'm so used
to traditional halo where you're in a
corridor and it's like okay if i'm
getting overwhelmed i can hide behind a
wall i can hide behind you know this
thing here but i literally felt
nick overwhelmed from all sides as soon
as i'm like yo
it was a different it was like a
helplessness but i loved it because i'm
like yo okay they're up there oh my god
they're all around and it was a sense of
overwhelming odds so to speak and i
never felt that really in it not that i
don't never felt it but it's rare so i
want to get your thoughts on it because
you've even pushed more on on zeta halo
more than i have and i want to get your
feel of now embarking on the outside and
all that
so like everybody else like i was very
lukewarm about the idea of halo going
into an open world and of course that
paranoia is stretched by you know the
plethora of you know open world games
that we have on a regular basis but what
always
pulls me into an open world game open
world games are always going to be
checklists that's period end of story
that's what it is but it's how
interesting you make those checklists to
achieve and then additionally making
the gameplay loop fun so that you want
to keep completing that that was what
was so brilliant by far cry 3. the
gameplay loop kept you doing all those
outposts and it's similar with halo
infinite because it's like we yes
there's so many more places enemies can
be and you have to constantly be on your
toes
but
that also lends itself to you having
more options in which you can approach
situations yes and that's what i think
is the beauty of this is like for
example one of the first outposts i
cleared i sat there and looked at him
there's all these guys all piled at the
bottom on the road i'm like ah that's a
lot of dudes i don't want to deal with
that and then i look up at the top and
there's one little grunt on a turret on
the hill on the right hand side i'm like
you know what i'm i'm just gonna go so i
sneak over there mail him in the back
he's quiet he's gone i just hop on the
turret and just start mowing down this
road of enemies
and
that is what's so great about this is
because yes
it sounds ridiculous but playing halo in
an open world is great because what
you're getting is you're getting the
sandbox
at its fullest ridiculous stuff
will happen yeah and that's the best
part about halos the ridiculous side of
it
yeah no absolutely it is it's that it's
the ultimate sandbox right and the
almost if you can think about it you can
do it right if you if you you have some
ingenuity with the way you want to
approach something you can do it also i
wanted to shout out i felt the game did
a really good job of like
cinematically just setting things up
almost over the top which i like because
i really felt it made me care more about
each moment to moment and situation and
getting uh level gameplay and i thought
that was cool so
again getting outside and i gotta say
the game looks good man it it really
from a visual standpoint i don't touch
too much but like i'm really i ain't in
my digital foundry got the frames and
all that out yet you just said but from
a visual aesthetic standpoint and the
way this game is running on series x i
was impressed what was your feeling from
from a graphical standpoint
yeah so i've done a lot i've got quite a
few previews under my belt now and what
most impressed me with this is just
utterly it's like the multiplayer flight
test where it's like this is incredibly
polished
for an early access version like i
didn't have texture pop in i wasn't
having frame drops
i you know the resolution was consistent
didn't see any weird tears or anything
else and i think that goes to show how
much work they've put into it because
this game looks nothing like the trailer
we saw a year ago now absolutely i mean
even when i noticed you know zooming in
on on chief and and the banished and and
just you know i just felt clearly we
have improved since the last showing
that we have seen and the extra time was
definitely was definitely worth it so um
now that you you know you're kind of out
there you're seeing what the gameplay
loop is you know to give me more of your
experiences and what you're expecting
out there on zeta halo
i think i think the most beautiful part
about
zeta halo and just how they have the
campaign design from what we were able
to play is the fact that it kind of
lends itself to both
types of what halo players are looking
for yes there's this open world you can
explore and everything else but that
linearity with levels is still there
when you're tackling main campaign
missions it's still there and there it's
not as guided but it's still it feels
like there's a purpose and i think
that's the biggest driver for making
this a great open world is that
everything you do has an impact it has a
purpose you get better vehicles you can
get better ordinance dropped and you
know you can unlock all these different
things like i
took over a it was like a scrap depot or
whatever and i took it over and i was
like man this is really great and
everything i had a blast but you know
what am i getting for this so i roll
into the garage and there's a scorpion
sitting there and it's like this is
yours now i'm like okay let's go and i'm
rolling out of there with the scorpion
so i'm rolling into my next outpost with
a scorpion and it just kind of it builds
on that and that's what's so great about
it is that
no outpost encounter feels the same it's
not like far cry where you're like all
right i'm gonna sneak in knife this guy
knife this guy knife this guy uh we'll
let a tiger out and then bada boom bada
bing it's clear there's always
this rogue element factor that will
throw you off like for the fuel depot i
sat there i cleared it out it was just
you know jackals grunts fuel eats no
problem and then this big elite was
invisible with an energy sword and he
came out of nowhere and just clocked me
and i was dead i was like whoa where
what what what happened
so i respawned in i i
kill all the people again and i'm
watching and i notice he's tucked in the
back corner of this garage as i spawn
back in okay and i'm like okay so he was
sitting there cloaked
the entire time i was fighting and then
the moment i was looking away from there
he attacked and i'm not sure if that's
an ai nod or if i got into his range or
wherever the case may be but
legitimately getting stabbed in the back
when i thought i was on a power streak
was
just a legitimately amazing feeling it
takes me back to like halo 2 where
you're playing legendary with your
friends you're like no no back back no
run run
[Music]
no no doubt man i love that aspect i i
love the uh liberation
of the marines and their inclusion to
trying to you know help you out and
stuff like that and that's always one
thing i've always loved about halo games
you know the feeling of okay you do have
some level of ai help even though they
may be cannon fodder or some levels but
all extra guns on deck definitely helps
and i thought that part was fun so you
know moving forward man now that you
we've got a lot of time with this thing
you know a bunch of hours for you know
for the most part you know how are we
feeling overall you know what i'm saying
and like but it's like overall like what
what is your
like outlook now you know how confident
are you like where are you at with halo
infinite campaign from what you played
so far now a lot can go wrong over the
course of a campaign obviously and
depending on how long something goes on
for is how you know might degrade your
level of fun
but right now as it sits with knowing
what the multiplayer is now and having
this experience with the campaign
this is some serious like this is going
to end up on a lot of people's game of
the year list like that that's that's
where i'm sitting like this is
this is a step a massive step forward
from halo 5
in terms of how it's delivering its
story what the actual story they're
delivering is and the gameplay aspects
this is the step forward they needed
after halo 4 that halo 5 did not
deliver on right
and i think this is three four threes
like this is it this is what people have
been asking for from them this is the
campaign this is the multiplayer this is
the best it's ever been
yeah i mean valid points i think you
know coming in from from a five my main
issue was i felt misdirected i felt that
you know marketing led me to believe one
thing the game ended up being somewhere
something else i didn't feel i connected
with a lot of the characters you know i
felt they were kind of just off screen
going a little too quickly the vibe i'm
getting right now is this is master
chief story right this is definitely in
store we are going to learn hopefully
more about what's going on here and i
think
immediately
it was a sense of relief because i'm
like wow this feels good it plays good
and now how do we transition how do we
transition to this quote-unquote open
world is that fully open world in the
sense of a traditional i guess like
assassin's creed type of game but it
what i like about it is what you said
earlier like you can kind of b-line and
do the main stuff and still be okay and
the other stuff but they reward you if
you kind of do the other stuff which is
really cool and you also find out lore
bits and stuff like that so i think my
initial feeling is very strong like i
was just like okay 343
you're showing me right now you're
taking the campaign very seriously i'm
very engrossed i love the aspect of the
open world and now i just want to know
where you go war with the narrative how
often like does it get redundant you
know saying do we do do we get bored do
we get different biomes like there's
still a couple of questions to answer
but initial feeling i'm with you like
very strong and i gotta admit man
i'm feeling good about this campaign man
i'm still feeling good i don't want to
jinx it but i'm feeling good man yeah i
feel it's it's one of those things where
like
for me like the campaign in recent
memory for halo that absolutely captured
me was halo wars 2.
yes
and
then
and they
capture what made the halo wars 2
campaign
and what made it special and put it into
the fps and that is just
it's everything i wanted from that
and also go play halo wars 2 because it
has one of the best campaigns oh ever
yeah you you need and you it's it's
great it's a great setup so uh yeah
that's what i got man again thanks for
myself for providing nicole we will be
providing more footage and you will be
having nicholas downey's amazing article
on logicgaming.net
going up at the same time in reference
to this campaign man but that's all i
got any other final thing before we get
up out of here nope always a pleasure
and uh can't wait to talk more about
halo in a couple of weeks
exactly so you know what to do stay
tuned here online podcast
lawsongaming.net for that halo infinite
coverage will provide as much as we can
to give you guys all the info you need
and that's all we got and we out of here
peace
[Music]
you